Let's discuss the features and tools within Sequencer and how they can impact your speed and efficiency when using them.
Working our way numerically from one to five, let's cover the Sequencer interface.
In section one, this is the toolbar, which is a collection of commonly used tools and settings within Sequencer.
We have the option to save the sequence,
browse to the sequence within the content browser, create a new camera and set it as the current camera cut,
export the sequence to a movie or image sequence via movie render queue,
open the blueprint director for the sequence,
execute various actions. Now, note many of these actions are available in the interface or with hotkeys.
Change your interface layout and the information that's displayed and
modify your playback options.
Now the next three menu options are some of the most commonly used when working with Sequencer.
The first option gives the ability to control default keying channels as well as keyframe interpolation.
The next option is auto keyframe, which will automatically create a key when parameters have changed.
A sequencer will only create a key if a previous key has been created.
And lastly, we can restrict Sequencer's ability to automatically create keys for properties when they're modified within the sequence, the level or both.
The viewport selectability button limits your ability to choose actors within the viewport.
When this button is active, you can only select objects using the sequence.
You can disable snapping or enable it as well as change the snapping interval.
You could modify the frame rate of the sequence.
Finally, you can use the curve editor for granular control over your keyframes.
Section 2 is the outliner. Actors and their properties that are part of the sequence are displayed in this section.
Note, typically only some of the actors' keyable properties will be shown here when the actor is added to the sequence.
You can add more keyable properties using the add button, the plus button,
located on the actors section or by adding a keyframe to the actors properties from a detail panel.
Section 3 is our timeline. As the playhead advances, it will progress through the various keyframes,
triggers, and events based on their position on the timeline.
Section 4 is the selection tab, which can be docked or the default fly-out,
and contains many of the same properties displayed when right-clicking an actor in the sequence.
Lastly, section 5 contains our playback controls,
buttons to specify our in and out points for the sequence or shot, and our timeline zoom and view options.
Now recent updates to Sequencer allows you to filter tracks based on your outliner selections.
You can isolate only the selected tracks, hide selected tracks, or display all.
After selecting a track or tracks, the sequencer curves editor can also be used to manipulate keyframes in keyframe interpolations.
Now across the top of the sequencer curve editor window are various features for displaying,
manipulating, scaling, and snapping your keyframes.
Additionally, you have the ability to set the keyframe interpolations as well as the in and out timings for those keyframes.
The add level sequence with shots tool is useful for automatically generating a master sequence that includes a structured hierarchy of
nested sequences and associated sequences all within a highly organized folder structure.
While you'll most likely find that this tool doesn't work perfectly for your established pipeline or
desired folder structure,
I highly recommend you play with it at least once to observe the way Unreal creates the parent sequence,
nested child sequences, and the file and folder structures.